[Música]
bom esse a gente dissesse aqui
que felicidade significa trabalhar para
ganhar um mínimo possível e não ter
quase nada bom em 2015
o economista angus dita ganhou o prémio
nobel da economia e entre outras coisas
os estudos dele se espalharam rápido
pelo mundo porque ele conseguia de uma
certa forma confirmar algo que a gente
sempre fala mas nunca tv como comprová
ele afirmava que dinheiro compra
felicidade sim ele até além
ele chegou até um número mágico da
felicidade 75 mil dólares o que
significa isso os estudos deles chegou à
conclusão que quando alguém recebe 75
mil dólares por ano o que equivale a 240
mil reais
essa pessoa tem um nível de satisfação
de vida muito maior porque ela não
precisa se preocupar com a falta de
dinheiro
essa é a conclusão de um dos estudos
dele e foi em 2014 que a diana e eu é
ultrapassamos essa cifra a gente ganhava
mais do que isso a gente trabalhava na
indústria da televisão eu dirigindo a
diana produzindo programas para o nerd
on discover e record globo e teve ea
gente era feliz de fato só que a gente
trabalhava tanto que não dava tempo para
pensar nisso e é referenciado em 2014 em
que a gente conseguiu tirar férias
juntas pela primeira vez ea gente
resolveu fazer uma trip uma viagem de
carro pelo sul dos estados unidos
a gente foi de nice fiel até moles uma
viagem música
ao passando por várias capitais da
música quando a gente voltou para o
brasil
a gente se surpreendeu olha o que a
gente chegou em casa a gente não se
sentiu em casa parecia que a gente tinha
ficado em algum lugar dessa experiência
isso faz a gente pensar que o que nos
faria feliz de verdade seria trabalhar
filmando pelo mundo devendo novas
experiências e conhecendo pessoas
diferentes e fazer disse nosso propósito
de vida
aí a gente começou a pensar em fazer uma
série de tv pra filmar videoclips com
bandas de rock pelo mundo
foi aí que nasceu a idéia de fazer o
projecto arrancou da world music filhos
que é a volta ao mundo em 80 videoclipe
foram sete meses tentando levantar
recursos para fazer com que essa idéia
sair do papel ea gente não conseguiu
foram sete meses trabalhando muito pra
fazer com que esse sonho se realizasse
ele afundou e levou com ele a nossas
cordura as financeiras
era final de ano a gente estava
frustrado um pouco preocupado não saber
exatamente o que a gente ia fazer ea
gente vai tirar férias foi bryan pra
trás parecer
e aí o léo levou com ele um livro que
ele estava lendo na época que o livro
linha d'água merckle link no qual amy
conta como ele tirou do papel a ideia de
do parte 2 que foi o veleiro que ele fez
a circum navegação tática
o léo logo nos primeiros capítulos uma
frase que ele dividiu comigo e que a
gente vai dividir com vocês agora
mesmo sabendo que o projeto todo minhas
finanças também andava beira de um
colapso
decidi correr o risco parando tudo
haveria uma dúvida quanto a esta sabe o
que fazer depois para seguir em frente e
eu sabia exatamente e que por mais
difícil que fosse o que deveria ser
feito
bom que quer risco né risco é quando a
gente tem um objetivo que a gente se
coloca vulnerável ou exposto ao perigo
o risco é quando a gente e coloca em
cheque ou melhor decide colocar em xeque
o nosso equilíbrio e nossa segurança
para conquistar o ter algum benefício
para realizar esse projeto que a gente
sonhava
depois de ler esta frase a gente pensou
a gente precisa correr risco a gente
precisa abrir mão do conforto que traz
felicidade pra gente e nas palavras do
ditran felicidade
dinheiro a gente tinha que abrir mão é
do dinheiro da estrutura de vida que a
gente tinha só que assim a gente
percebeu que a gente não ligava para
manter o salário que a gente tinha e
muito menos a estrutura da vida que a
gente tinha a gente queria mesmo era
realizar esse projeto
nesse momento a gente pensou assim por
mais óbvio que a gente falou nós mas
quem decide a estrutura de vida que a
gente quer
somos nós mesmos e depois disso a gente
define o quanto a gente precisa ganhar
para sustentar sua vida que a gente quer
para pensar já que a gente sempre tem
tempo pra é sonhar como seria nossa vida
com mais dinheiro ganhando mais
mas a gente nunca tem tempo para pensar
como seria nossa vida o metade das
coisas que a gente tem um sonho com isso
é um demérito ganhar menos tem menos
nesse momento o jogo virou pra gente ea
gente começou uma grande revolução na
nossa vida
a gente percebeu que o trabalho do
futuro o nosso trabalho do futuro
dependia da vida que a gente queria hoje
e aí a gente resolveu vender todos os
nossos bens no brasil e partir para esse
projeto que iria mudar completa
também de nosso futuro porque pra viver
18 meses na estrada
a gente não precisava ter uma casa
a gente precisava de um lugar para morar
a gente não precisava ter um carro a
gente precisava de um meio de locomoção
a gente também não precisava ter um
guarda roupa cheio de opções
a gente precisava de uma mala cada ea
gente também não ia ter durante todo
esse esse projeto toda aquela estrutura
que a gente estava acostumada de equipe
equipamento que tinha nos nossos
trabalhos em televisão seriam só nós
dois ea gente iria aprender a fazer a
função de todos esses profissionais e
até que se virar com que a gente
encontrar pelo caminho
foi uma revolução que atingiu em cheio a
nossa forma de consumo
quanto menos a gente consumia e tinha
mais tempo e liberdade agente
conquistava e quanto mais liberdade mas
a vida a gente vivia
esse projeto terminou há um ano a gente
concluiu os 80 videoclipes pelo mundo e
foi um movimento tão forte de
transformação na gente que meio que como
por inércia a gente não conseguiu mais
pará que o que tinha sido
temporariamente uma moda de vida hoje
virou nosso padrão de vida a gente
continua não tendo uma casa não tendo
carro e vivendo cada um com uma mala que
a gente aprendeu nessa história quanto
menos coisa a gente tem
- a gente tem pra perder mais destemido
a gente vai ser mais corajoso a gente
vai ser mais disposto a gente vai ser a
gente aprendeu que vulnerabilidade traz
muito mais comprometimento ea gente
aprendeu que quanto menos tempo a gente
gasta para manter uma grande estrutura
mas tempo sobra pra gente investir
em vida e vamos lá gente que foi o que
dinheiro nessa história é uma coisa
super importante de falar
dinheiro não é o que a gente tem no
bolso não é o que a gente tem no banco
dinheiro é o tempo que a gente gasta
ganhando dinheiro dinheiro é o tempo que
a gente gasta para manter uma grande
estrutura de vida
é a gente pergunta pra vocês o trabalho
então não deveria ser aquela atividade
que a gente faz para aproveitar a vida
ea vida não deveria ser o tempo que a
gente tem aqui pra ser feliz
a resposta dessas duas perguntas for sim
então quer dizer que viver com menos não
é uma filosofia sobre o consumo ou sobre
a economia é uma filosofia sobre a
felicidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]